you know we have generate the younger
people are always the ones who come up
and change my mind and actually want to
talk about it it's the oh it's the
Millennials what's doing that gap busy
shirt is that writing or is that just a
pattern it's a Hawaiian shirt oh okay
all right you from Hawaii oh no I'm a
Hollywood's new favorite socialist what
your what Hollywood okay there yes I
like it I like it okay see it now you
know I didn't see it before the red
pants the hair yeah you get the hair
more okay Ace Ventura alright I
appreciate it was just a last-minute
costume and it wasn't quite like the mug
guy he's like it's last-minute so you
got a tank top and a shirt that kinda I
don't know like Jim Carrey it's pretty
close all right okay what's your name
sir Eli Eli all right Eli we're going
Old Testament what would you like what's
your question my question is so I'm 18
so I don't have to identify with
Millennials thank God wait you're a
lucky yes and lucky until important [ __ ]
said Kevin Spacey from a cell continue
I'm sure could give me an Aloha
stop stop stop clapping I'm terrible all
right go ahead but no so do you have any
hope for Gen Z you know being more
conservative they've kind of talked
about oh absolutely
so what do you what do you see us doing
or what do we have to do to finally get
the country going so your generation Z
at 18 where does in racing Z start
exactly in 1990 something you can
identify I could tell it's like 96 what
social security like what I'm like I
know I could pick it later and
technically get more but I just want to
steal stuff now they're like okay no
listen this is Trey and I appreciate you
I thank you for the question Eli this is
actually a really important question
generation Z is possibly the most
conservative generation ever now I know
yeah I mean you know that's why they
were so busy trying to push David hog
out that's a great example generation Z
is probably more pro-gun than it don't
boo me I say is it's not like Voldemort
okay I like sitting in the boo because
you're Canadian so generation Z is
probably more pro-gun than any
generation prior why they talked about
gun culture 2.0 because you've played
these video games where you see these
ultra realistic guns you want to try
them out shoot them or not even
necessarily pro-second amendment and
then all of a sudden that kind of folds
into that also tend to be very Pro free
speech and here's something that I've
noticed and I actually think as is um I
haven't heard a lot of people talk about
this is entirely a theory it's
conjecture okay so wait hold please tell
me you're dressed as a terrorist I
couldn't see you until just now
delicious food by the way I think there
was a place actually what was the place
that actually was funneling money to
Hezbollah it's the sheesh right or
possibly all of them but let's go with
Lachish it was the sheesh yes I remember
and listen you know they hate the Jews
but by God their tabbouleh is tasty so
generation Z there are winning issues
pro-gun CRO free speech they've rejected
this sort of pseudo third wave feminism
there's a lot of progress being able
generation Z and this is just kind of a
theory that I have you know Millennials
were sort of the last generation to
bridge that gap with social media right
Millennials when you when we and I guess
technically millennial at thirty one I'm
not entirely sure
one person's like a cheer and then
everyone's booing because I'm still
Canadian I get it I'm gonna leave very
soon people are terrible I'm never
coming back to Ann Arbor no I'm coming
back
and then we're gonna go up to Torch Lake
and take a dump of Michael Moore's dock
[Applause]
otherwise P were like Michael Moore
receives an envelope he's pretty sure
it's the guy who said he's gonna take a
dump on its dock so we were the last
generation when I grew up we didn't we
didn't have face but we'd have Twitter
damn snapchat the closest thing was
later on we had MySpace and that sort of
became like the whorehouse of the
internet before that there was
Friendster before that there was Stanga
which was it was just nothing but it was
nothing but Asians and and you know God
Indians were on xanga we didn't really
have it right so that's the last
generation where remember you didn't
really get the red pen scores had to be
evened out because you could insulate
those kids we had kids who were bullied
a little bit too much when you go to
baby boomers and Generation X when we we
had sort of we just tossed them all on a
school together right we created the
federal Department of Education let's
say let's see what happens here okay
it's not really working out that well
people are getting their asses kicked
test scores aren't really going up but
then generation Z they've been raised
now with social media their entire life
which is terrible in a way because the
worst things you can possibly read right
you see on social media it's toxic I
it's just like a drug you really need to
keep usage of it absolutely limited not
today Twitter Instagram Facebook crowd
are you of em takeover
shameless plug you can't really hide and
so I don't think professors I don't
think parents are able to insulate
Generation Z so much so you have this
generation right Millennials who kind of
made it to college had been told that
they're amazing and they're perfect
every way that they were and none of us
are and they went there and there was a
reality check in the workplace when she
no kinds of problems of Millennials in
the workplace where's generations II
have been told the most horrendous thing
that could possibly imagine since they
could use a smartphone and so I think
that'll have negative ramifications but
again they have the ability to fat check
any both crap same thing anything I've
said here tonight he's full of crap
they're half the time that's what
generation Z and they're very pro-gun
Pro free speech so I actually have a lot
of hope for Generation Z I see far more
people who are willing to listen and
engage in a conversation because once
you cut through the white noise of all
the terrible crap being said on social
media you know we have generated the
younger people
are always the ones who come up and
change my mind and actually want to talk
about it it's the oh it's the
Millennials doing that gap so I really
do think the tides it fit the pendulum
swings the other way and generations II
statistically as well something else
that's undeniable they are more
conservative right now at this point in
their lives then baby boomers were so
right now let me go well they're really
not that conserver their liberal yeah
their liberal but that's expected when
you're young but for the first time we
actually have sometimes on certain
issues a plurality of Generation Z
folks what do you call them generations
ears zere's the tree again dammit
Caitlyn Jenner I'm not going to x-man
cover go with it they are more
conservative on certain issues than any
generation before them at that snapshot
in time in their lives and that's one we
don't hear about it's something to look
out for it's some really good news and
it's also oh I want fewer and fewer
people to be afraid because Generation Z
is not as cowardly as many Millennials
were and that really warms my heart
thank you so much you live for your
question I appreciate it you were if you
like this video you first off should
probably seek counseling but you should
subscribe or hit the notification bell
or watch one of these videos that's
playing what the truth is I don't know
what any of that means anymore if you
try and subscribe at the notification
bell you won't be notified and if you
try click one of these videos it's just
going to take you to BuzzFeed boldly fat
frauds as they get carried out of their
houses we're late to break down the
north wall and they get carried out in a
land well tarp I don't know what's
happening on YouTube I know what's
happening with mug Club Laden's credit
calm slash monk let me get to watch The
Daily Show one hour every single day not
just clips along with like 15 other
shows for 69 dollars annually if your
student and/or veteran or military and
you get to keep us here on YouTube for
free because we can we can irritate them
by your support it's worth it right